it would be like walking up to the to
the betting window and be like yeah I'm
gonna place a bet on this team and you
you picked the wrong team and then you
intended they give you the slip your
team loses you go to rip up the slip and
you look that you oh I made a mistake oh
I bet on the other team oh I won on
[ __ ] just okay great like literally
that's the job of an investor you just
don't know which ones are gonna win so
you just basically treat everybody who's
in your portfolio amazing you try to
just be as supportive as possible which
is you know again as the life is pretty
simple you just find the best people you
can invest in them support the heck out
of them if it doesn't work out and they
did a good job that on them again
Jason Calacanis in the building how are
you what what how you doing
funny on the part you are in the most
beautiful studio that I think of
everything and you're in your and you're
in your bedroom I am with a lighthouse
poster with a lot with a lighthouse
poster behind you with a house poster in
to eat that is but you know we're all
starting somewhere with a wave crashing
around it anyway it's very it's chaos
right what were we talking about just
before we started some chaos going on
here Cass well wait what where is that
lighthouse I'm not sure I'm gonna have
some specific meeting what would Freud
say about picking a lighthouse and the
edge of human existence that's being
pummeled by giant waves what would that
say about a man who puts that as the
first thing he sees when he wakes up in
the last thing he sees when he goes to
bed can you tell that I'm a bit of a
loner can you tell that I'm an only
child Jason it does scream I'm alone at
the edge of existence yes can you tell
that I'm so maybe you're opting into it
see that's the thing about lighthouse
operators they're opting into it
nobody's forcing there it's not a jail
so there's a certain type of person who
wants that solitude Jason what's that
that gig incredibly incredibly
perceptive my friend there you go all
right well welcome to this week in Freud
let me take it over in the first 30
seconds that's five do you [ __ ] so
here's a question for you I podcasting
as a host which you are do you find it
odd being on the other side of the mic
sometimes you slip in a host mode
I do slip into host mode sometimes and I
do start thinking like no this is the
question you should ask and you know if
you want me to answer that question you
asked me four questions just the second
one is the winner that's what the
audience why she wants to hear or why
didn't you ask me this follow-up
question yes that does go through my
mind sometimes it happens it makes it
very hard for me to listen to other
podcasts because it becomes so obvious
to me when the person who's doing
conducting the interview doesn't know
what they're doing and then it really
makes it amazing when
you listen to you know Howard Stern
interviewing Hillary Clinton or Joe
Rogan interviewing Sam Harris or Sam
Harris interviewing anybody you know you
start to realize Wow some people are
really great at this right and they all
have different styles and stylistically
you know many different styles work in
some cases it's very difficult for me
when I know more than the subject that
was the thing I had to unlock as an
interviewer sometimes I have somebody
who's a guest and they know less about
the topic we're talking about than I do
that doesn't often happen but let's say
it's angel investing or media or
something where I've spent you know a
decade or two doing it and they're a
young founder I they're actually
deferring to me and sometimes they might
say well what do you think and that's
problematic in fact Evan Williams who is
very good at media but I think we know
where he's more success than I am having
done Twitter and medium and blogger but
you know I created better editorial
brands at him certainly with Engadget in
this week in startups like singular
editorial property so we have like long
conversations when I interviewed him
every time I'd ask what question said
what do you think you didn't you did
these other publications you know you
just look in on reporter or what are you
thinking like well you're on stage in
front of 2,000 people right now I'm the
interviewer so sometimes with people who
are my friends or whatever I'll just say
hey listen I might ask you a basic
question that you know I know the answer
to or that you might be interested in my
answer but just humor me for the sake of
the audience and and sometimes even
interview I'll say hey for the sake of
the audience can you explain what this
is and I added that to my repertoire
because every time I'd say what's you
know a seat what's the what's a CPM
explain CPM they'd be like you don't
know what CPM is and you've been in the
advertising business so I was like no I
know the audience so then I have this
way of coaching it and framing the
question explain to the audience or
explain to somebody who doesn't know
what CPM means cost per thousand right
anyway you have to you learn I think
somewhere after two or three hundred of
these like interviews you get good at it
problem is most people in life no I mean
it's not a joke
either I mean I think a lot of people in
life think like well I've done ten
podcast episodes like
here we go where's my you know what why
are the ads not sold and it's like you
might want to get to your three or four
you know you might want to get a hundred
two hundred three hundred reps under
your belt everybody thinks like they go
to the you know they shoot a hundred
three-pointers and that their stuff car
it's not exactly how it works maybe if
you shoot like you know a thousand a day
for a hundred days you you know you
might start to understand what shooting
involves well somewhere around the 1000
what makes a good Plus can podcast of
them the best podcasters in my
estimation are people who can't work for
anybody else and who don't want to work
for anybody else and who are fearless
and they have some level of respect from
their audience so if you look at Joe
Rogan if you look at ben shapiro if you
look at Bret Easton Ellis if you look at
the Red Scare dasha and Anna if you look
at Sam Harris Leo Laporte any of those
folks they are not working for anybody
but themselves
you cannot aggregate them into a podcast
company God knows people have tried Bill
Simmons as well
they are singular voices who don't
answer to anybody and so authentically
connected with their audience that you
know they're gonna say what they believe
no matter what and I think this goes to
you know the influence Howard Stern had
on the the format of radio Howard Stern
was somebody considered shock jock in
the 80s and 90s in New York City and
eventually went across the country here
in America and you do shocking stuff you
know we'd have strippers on the podcast
he would have you know a clue Klux Klan
member on the pockets it's very
outrageous but then he kind of evolved
and you started realizing wow he's so
authentic and his interview style is so
incredible that he gets people to share
things that nobody else does and they
feel comfortable doing that and that had
a I think a deep impact on me not the
strippers and the Ku Klux Klan members
but the latter which is he's authentic
right you know what he's saying is real
I think Charlie Rose also had that when
he was on air you know you knew he was
like actually reading the books or cared
about the topics he was an intellectual
a public
two electoral wanted to have these like
really incredible discussions Morley
Safer Oprah Winfrey you know there's a
cohort of people who just got really
good at peer reviewing people and and
you can see that in podcast and the
recent podcast is getting so popular
right now is because the press and
journalism and media is so broken and
that's leading to people wanting to if
you're are subject who was in the press
a lot like Sam Harris was in the press a
lot or Joe Rogan might be or Leo Laporte
might be or Bill Simmons you know they
were essentially throttled or mediated
through the press and when they got on a
podcast as the host now there's nobody
editing them then you have their guests
on and then the guests are like wait a
second you're gonna give me three hours
to explain my point two hours an hour
and I'm gonna get misquoted by a
journalist and there's why journalism is
really struggling right now is the the
people who know the most are going
direct to the audience and journalists
by definition only on know five ten
twenty percent of the story that's what
I have to do research that's why they
have to hit the pavement but because
they don't control distribution anymore
and they only have ten or 20 percent
knowledge of the situation they can't
compete with the people who are on the
inside they can't compete with people
like me who you know invest in these
companies they don't have the knowledge
base I have the journalists can't
they're not doing it every day right and
I was a journalist I was a founder and
now I'm an investor and I'm still you
know quasi journalists doing my podcast
so it's a really fascinating time and I
think podcasting is a reaction to link
baiting SEO driven content content
farming and just the collapse of
newspapers and magazines and those
editorial formats websites people don't
do fact checking and they write link
baiting stories people are tired of that
nonsense and they want to go to the
depth of a podcast where people feel
that they're not going to be misquoted
because I just gave you a six minute
answer to your question as opposed to
you gave me two lines in your story and
just pick the ones that you think are
the you know most interesting or you
know most likely to get retweeted the
thing as well is that the ability to
have time to play with ideas right to
sandbox with ideas
to be subtle and nuanced and and say
something which you isn't even quite
formed whereas if you were to do an
interview with a reporter and you play
around an idea which isn't quite formed
and then that gets transcribed that's
precisely the the loophole that they
were looking for right I think so I
think that's exactly right cool so I
want to ask everybody that's listening
we'll have heard Silicon Valley angel
investing but for me is someone who
likes to think that he is curious
intellectually and learns about the
world and just this podcast and we're on
episode this will be around about
episode 150 so I might be about halfway
to your bar of knowing having an idea
about what I'm doing you make you'll get
a proper microphone by episode 200 so
right he under 50 a music earpods what
the heck's going on here right here all
right all right yeah that's my boy Jason
all right well you know you come on the
podcast and you're in your bedroom and
you got air pods on or you not even have
ear pods on you got you you got cable
the headphones on but you do have this
short SMB 7mm MBRs M so that's assess
myself oh by the way sm7b minute cloud
lifter or DNI D 14 we've got able to set
up is here don't let it don't let it
fool you and but yeah so silicon Bob's
your mom gonna come in with fish sticks
she come in with fish sticks any minute
now
that's actually well because we're
running about 15 minutes late I've had
to text her and let I know that she
needs to push those back a tiny little
bit push the fish takes back a little
bit yeah just little bangers and mash
coming what do you got nice that's some
classic we should be a food for you
there any mushy peas there some chips
tea I like that fish emergency oh I love
a little take I'm how a multi right now
hey I like it we did you come in do you
walk in with kombucha as well no I don't
I don't fact we can boot you up an
adulterer
I'm a capitalist we don't [ __ ] with
kombucha yeah man I'm not paying you
eight dollars for something like
fermented like whatever
come on something that someone else is
already digested yeah Adam yeah and that
[ __ ] weekend booyah
sorry don't you write such quotable I
think that's quotable somebody put that
on the reddit sub J Cal's not [ __ ]
with conclusion right you get a read at
Sabu Silicon Valley right angel
investing it's a words that get thrown
around a lot I want to come to Floyd
Mayweather
angel invest in Silicon Valley and I
want to learn how to throw a jab I want
to understand the structure of the
industry I don't know what seed
extension is I don't know what series A
or Series B or any of this [ __ ] I
want to know how the industry works can
you can you tell us how the industry
works Jason yes I can so there are
companies being started all the time
right there are mom-and-pop companies
there are pizzerias there are movies and
CDs created the and this is all
entrepreneurship going on in the world
right somebody might start a design
agency somebody might start a PR agency
drycleaner you get the idea and these
are all great businesses they can employ
people sometimes the owner can make a
nice salary and be independent sometimes
they can make even more than that they
can make a life for themselves right so
that's all fine and well what we do in
Silicon Valley and in the venture
capital industry is we look for the
outlier companies companies that can
grow at a velocity that would be
considered unrealistic inhuman bizarre
to other people and the best analogy I
heard on this is that you know venture
capital is like jet fuel it's 40 or
rocket fuel you wouldn't put rocket fuel
like on a Vespa would not work out well
like you're not trying to go Mach
whatever you know on those those
vehicles so those vehicles are fine they
don't need a lot of money to start them
you can start a consulting firm
for $0 today you can just literally put
up a free website and you can email a
thousand people and say here's what I do
and you know get three customers the the
businesses we invest in you know if you
were to look at one like uber or Robin
Hood or calm calm these are businesses
that were intended to impact hundreds of
millions of people a billion people you
know large numbers of people and you
know that is a different type of
business and it requires a different
type of capital and a different type of
plan
most of those businesses fail and when
they do fail they fail hard so you have
to also have a different expectation if
you're starting a consulting firm you're
really not gonna fail there's nothing
really at stake right like what if I we
set up a website today and say we're
gonna do a podcast consulting company
you know C&J podcast consulting and
we're gonna teach people how to do
podcast like okay if we get one customer
a year or ten or a hundred like okay I
guess it's a success it's more than zero
whereas with a start-up like uber or com
you know you're you're building
something that is more complex and has a
smaller chance of success but if it does
succeed oh my lord
it could change the fabric of society
and humanity forever and many companies
have like Google Facebook ooh BRR Airbnb
these things are changing society and in
order to do that it's sort of an Olympic
caliber sport so that is the difference
right now yeah you know that's that's
the main difference in the type of
companies we invest in and so that's
where most of the confusion comes in
people want to start a company that
makes you know ginger beer or tea or
they're doing a company that has a noble
purpose and it's like these do not
qualify for the one in a thousand or one
in 10,000 chance of an outlier therefore
you're not fundable by this industry and
that turns people off sometimes the
initiating and they don't understand it
or if I told you you're going to start
ten businesses six are going to zero
the seventh and eighth will return half
the amount of money you put into them
the ninth will return two or three times
what you put into it and maybe if you
get lucky the 10th or the 20th or the
30th might return more than 30 X you put
in a dollar more than X so it's a type
of gambling and risk-taking that is very
unique very confusing from the outside
and even from the inside the people who
do this kind of gambling struggle with
their own psychology and their own
existence so it's no doubt that it's
confounding to everybody yes
to begin with our tech stocks whether
when he goes due to scalability is it
just the fact that that has the ability
to really rock it off yeah so I mean if
you look at public stocks yeah I mean if
you invested in Google Netflix or Amazon
you know at their IPO or anytime after
the first five years of those companies
you'd be pretty happy today I think
Facebook as well and so the companies
are getting much larger today than they
ever have and I think they've become
very resilient because they've been
adding multiple business lines in a way
that previous companies didn't so it
used to be companies were one-trick
ponies they went public in year six
seven now you have company staying
private and going publics in year ten
eleven twelve thirteen and they're
they're much larger businesses so much
stronger businesses and then once they
get public they get more ambitious they
start doing acquisitions and they become
super resilient so the resiliency of a
company like Facebook having bought
whatsapp oculus and Instagram three huge
bats or Google having bought Android
YouTube much stronger businesses and
then even in the classic businesses like
Disney having bought Pixar Marvel and
Star Wars you know those companies now
make them so much stronger that they're
not reliant on just the Disney IP you
know Snow White and Mickey Mouse which
you know those things could fall out of
favor but now they get this new life
because they have all the Marvel
characters well the Pixar characters and
all the Star Wars characters and all
those worlds to just keep building and
building and building so
I I think buying those kind of stocks
and I'm not a public stock picker it
feels like there's very little downside
because the idea that Amazon or Google
would go away anytime soon or perhaps
even in our lifetime does not seem
realistic we did see Yahoo go out of
business so previously when they were
one-trick ponies like Yahoo was or other
companies yeah it might be more it might
be possible like you know buying eBay or
something that's been a pretty resilient
business but you know they've they've
got one business really and you know
that does make it difficult I got it so
or more child let's go back to the we're
investing in private companies yeah yeah
yeah let's go back to private where do
you find these people you walking down
the street you see some guy who's got a
t-shirt on and says I own a startup like
what happens so the way I meet people is
you know I have a podcast and amongst
founders I would be you know a celebrity
on the scale of Lady gaga or Michael
Jordan and then absolutely it's getting
a little uncomfortable in the second
half of the hour you know but outside of
the industry I'm a nobody right so when
I lived in LA and I would go to industry
parties nobody would know who I was and
then when I'm in an industry party you
know I might get asked to take ten
selfies in the tech business and it
really is a popularity contest amongst
investors investors have brands and
people want to be affiliated with
different brands so you might make an
analogy of like Creative Artists Agency
or endeavor and the different agencies
William Morris Agency whatever in
Hollywood you get affiliated with an
agency or you got affiliated as a
musician with a record label
you know you then become validated you
become anointed in a way and it gives
other people permission to engage with
your startup or in the case of CIA and
agencies or labels music tours whatever
movies so a lot of what we do here is we
anoint people
and we fund them and then we tell them
where the landmines are and we say you
know let us know if you make it to the
other side and how we can help and you
know it's it really is basically like
you're sending you know these Sounders
into a warzone and you see who makes it
to the other side we see who you know
the good news is it's not fatal you know
and so if you fail and two out of three
or three out of four startups fail
depending on you know how you measure it
might be even greater based on you know
the number of experiments being run
today by founders you need only start
three four or five companies to have a
likelihood of success right so that's
what I tell people when they when their
first company fails is that like you
know Travis's third company was uber you
know Ilan's third one two three a third
or fourth third and fourth companies
were SpaceX and Tesla right so a lot of
times people do their best work on that
third time up at bat fourth time up at
bat that actually seems to be a sweet
spot right you're not like as nervous
some people Bill Gates Jeff Bezos Mark
Zuckerberg they hit the home run right
out of the park that's not common it's
memorable so there's a survivorship bias
to it
the fact that those companies have
become big or confirmation bias rather
not survivorship
well maybe it's it's uncommon amongst
too many situations right it is very
uncommon for somebody and their first
company to hit a giant outlier success
but because when it does happen it's so
memorable that it feels more common than
it is which I believe is the definition
of confirmation bias or survivorship
bias about survivorship bias is like
okay well these people survived
therefore there was something you you
the fact that they survived you read
something into who will survive the next
time right the the problem with that was
the the way they can't they've figured
out survivorship bias was they looked at
planes in World War two that had
actually where the bullet holes were
when they landed and they found the
bullet holes you know were in all these
different places and they were like okay
this is what we need to fix whatever
what they didn't realize is those are
the planes that made it back got hit in
the wing and didn't get hit in the
cockpit or the engine so it turns out
that they weren't including in the
sample where the pullets were on the
planes that went down because they
couldn't recover those planes cuz they
blew up in the sky
those ones got hit in the cockpit and
the pilot got killed or they got hit in
the engine and the gas tank exploded
right so you get this weird you know
bias that is you know not and that and
that's one of the reasons why people who
are in the VC industry are constantly
trying to figure out the cognitive
frameworks and biases in this podcast
just about these things and there's
people studying just these things so
that we as people placing the bats can
try to figure out a model to unlock this
like it's the Fountain of Youth or
something right and and that's a major
problem for people is that that the
randomness that occurs here fools people
right and and then they start thinking
oh well I hit Ober therefore I'm a great
picker and and that's just not the case
right like I don't think I'm a great
picker I think I have a great Network
and I have great relationships sounds
like there's a lot of chaos going oh
yeah I mean one way to think about this
job of venture capitalists or just
investor in startups is 99% of my time
is spent on the failed companies so let
me just say that again
you know if you invest in you know a
hundred companies over your career and
you look back on the time you spend in
all likelihood you're gonna have spent
something in the range of 90% on the
companies that failed the companies that
succeed you go to the board meetings
they turn over the results and you go
well that's more than we expected and
you're like everyone pops everyone else
on the buck high-five a bunch of
high-fives yeah I mean and you know I've
had this in the number of times in my
career where it's going up and to the
right and the last thing I want to do is
go you know hey let's spend some time
together screwing up your formula right
just use work doing you you keep on
pushing whatever button you push in yeah
yeah I mean you could study it to figure
out if you can accelerate it
study it to figure out if there are
margin issues competitive issues there's
a lot to do even on the successful
companies like when your company scale
you need to hire a lot of people you
need to watch out for competitors you
need to build infrastructure you need to
have things in place that keep this very
fast-moving rocket ship from blowing up
as it you know gets to orbit it's the
ones that never even you know get the
Rockets to the launch pad you know that
I spend a lot of time on it's like okay
is the rocket finished great okay are we
gonna fire the rocket oh there's no jet
fuel in the rocket okay great okay oh
you don't have any extra knots either
okay we kind of heard to get into space
without those two things we're gonna
need some jet fuel I'm gonna need some
astronauts like you know I'm gonna have
to finish the rocket Oh
the Rockets not done okay we gotta
finish the rocket you've got any chance
to get into orbit so it's it's a chaotic
job the last week just to give you a
picture of my life with over 200
investments the last week I've spent
dealing with you know chaos at four
companies so 2% of the company is just
completely chaotic you know and with
these startups they're almost inevitably
running out of money and facing
existential threats externally where
Google's gonna make their product free
let's say or you know they're getting
really well-funded competitors who then
decide they're gonna give away hundred
dollar bills for 50 bucks and take all
the customers you know we just lifted
with uber and uber did with other people
like they get into these crazy you know
Wars of discounting and you know it's
pretty scary so yeah I deal with a lot
of chaos so how much sorry Jason how
much that's why I like your budget or so
much massaging people I'm just saying
let's everyone chill out let's bring a
little bit of water to this chaos ya
know a big part of my job that's why I
liked your lighthouse poster so much is
you know when you look at that
lighthouse it's like yeah there's a
giant wave as nature doesn't you don't
get the sense that that lighthouse is
gonna get knocked over right and that's
really my job is the job of the founder
is of any leader is to convince
everybody that there is a plan and
that we can succeed if we follow the
plan and we stick together and we
execute at the highest level possible
our chances if we work together our
greater then if we don't have a plan and
we don't work together and so a lot of
what I will be talking to a founder
about is okay what a success look like
what's the plan to get to success who do
we need to be on the team to get to
success okay what are the other tactical
issues going on oh we're being sued by
this person oh we have to get out of
this lease or oh my god we've you know
got these competitors okay great but
let's focus on what's the goal what's
the plan and who do we need to execute
the plan to achieve the goal and it's
very hard to stay focused you know when
there's bombs going on all over the
place it's very hard and you know I
spend some time working on an ambulance
and it was always taken by the the
people who were in charge my brother's a
firefighter and lieutenant and you know
when you watch those leaders in really
chaotic situations they just come in
with a surgical precision and this level
of calm where they're running into
burning buildings or you know my first
call on an ambulance was the night
before Thanksgiving and maybe the late
80s early 90s and somebody had been
stabbed right above their heart and it
was like oh this person could die so if
there's a coin toss situation and just
watching the calm at which people were
able to triage these situations always
very impressive to me and I always think
about samurai or Jedi in that regard
which is why there's a poster of Toshiro
Mifune in the office and you know if you
look at samurais or Jedi Knights who
were modeled off of samurai I think it's
a very good metaphor for leadership
which is like these are very powerful
people who don't often take out the
sword they're gonna figure out solutions
they're very focused and they're they
know how to block out what is not
essential right so it's a great scene
where qui-gon jinn is fighting Darth
Maul and these
this wall gets like a laser wall good
it's blocking the two of them and Darth
Maul is like pacing back and forth like
a cheetah you know like in a cage and
qui gong Jim just kneels down turns off
the lightsaber and meditates and closes
his eyes yeah and you know really that's
like I'm gonna conserve my energy here
and think about what the right decision
is because those doors are gonna open
and it's gonna be chaos and if you look
at a scene like the movie Gladiator
there's a scene where Maximus says
listen whatever anybody here in the Army
great
come come next to me we're gonna fight
together whatever comes through those
doors we have a better chance of
succeeding if we fight together as one
and he gives this big as one speech you
can look it up or there's a nother great
scene in a movie called Black Hawk Down
where the snipers say listen we got to
go in and protect the pilots of that
other Black Hawk drop us in and they
said listen we we don't know when we're
gonna have reinforcements so if we're
dropping you in I need you to confirm
with me that that's what you want and
that you recognize that we don't know
when we can get your reinforcements or
if we can ever get reinforcements there
and we're dropping you into this hostile
territory where it's gonna be the two
snipers versus thousands of Somalians
who are armed and are surrounding the
helicopter and you know that's how I use
those metaphors because they in each of
those cases people are working together
and they're blocking out things that are
not important and they're focused on
what is important and that really is
what entrepreneurship and leadership is
about that ability to focus in slow down
take that breath and say okay this is a
dangerous situation this is a critically
dangerous situation this is a you know
they're gonna drop us in to this you
know situation in Somalia and we're not
gonna get out in all likelihood but
we're gonna take that chance anyway and
we're just gonna focus and let our
training and our plan execute itself you
know whatever happens now those are all
violent crazy situations but those are
the metaphors I choose I'm sure somebody
else can come up with a much more
peaceful one but God in my experience
it's a [ __ ] war I like yours I like
your wanna cool ones running these Reese
companies is a [ __ ] war it really is
and and that and that's just a
successful ones you know the ones that
are not successful you know it's
you know it's a war and chaos and whilst
fighting the corona virus virus yeah
exactly like those are and those are
things that are outside of your control
you know imagine you're in the hardware
business right now which is hard enough
you're do building a hardware startup
and you've got shipments coming from
China or you're supposed to have your
hardware solution you know that clients
paid for and now it's you know lost in
customs or something there's a business
disruption business eruption for Apple
with hundreds of billions of dollars in
the bank no problem
this is corruption with somebody with
six or twelve months of runway in the
bank big problem how much of what you've
alluded to there which is your ability
to work out the controllables and the
uncontrollables bring a little bit of
order to this chaos how much of that is
learned and how much of that is your
Constitution and if it's learned and
what elements are would you be able to
talk about a routine or any of the
things that you do which tend to help
you with that regard well I would say
you know some folks are the product of
their environments and that's their
primary drivers and other folks are very
good at adding skills and you know I I
think you could probably do both
you know Tim Ferriss The Seeker as I
call him you know he seeks out knowledge
and he learns that any advances and
learns very quickly that's kind of his
thing he just adapts and learns new
skills very quickly so it's clearly can
be done but there is at its core I do
think you know some situations that are
high-pressure that people grow up in
that do define them and so one theory I
heard I don't know if this is correct or
has any basis but it it certainly is an
interesting one to consider is that a
lot of the great founders who are good
and operating in chaos and under stress
had a situation where one parent loved
them very much in one parent maybe
wasn't as available or was actively
cruel or mean and that person then had
to balance and learn to solve this
problem every day of their life and
their childhood right sure
to parents you know one who loved them
and one who was chaotic or something and
they had to just make sense and navigate
that it doesn't ring true to me I mean
obviously we see over and over again
immigrants really over perform an index
you know in terms of the percentage of
them leading very large companies and
their leadership ability something about
immigrant parents and you know the the
work ethic that maybe people see in
their parents when they work three jobs
and they put in 60 78 hours a week and
they force their kids to study because
they say I don't want you to have to
work 90 hours a week you know there's
something positive about that which is
you know why it's a little bit
heartbreaking that we have this
nationalism where we don't want to let
in the people who are taking the
greatest risk in the world leaving one
country to come to another to try to
make a better life it's like those
people are you know under such
incredible duress just doing that that
they become exceptional citizens I think
by and large and become incredible for
those countries that get to receive that
gift right like if you look now in
Silicon Valley the the number of Indian
Americans who are leading companies out
here is just extraordinary and we had
just a massive influx of Indians who
suffered greatly you know in in their
journey here and to build a new life
here face racism faced you know having
to work menial jobs to build stuff up
and an incredible work ethic and
incredible focus on education and now
Microsoft Google I mean the number of
Indian Americans running companies is
just stunning and amazing and now we
want to not let them in to the country
it's bonkers right I mean it's very sad
for England it's very sad for America
how about for you know how about you
talk to me about your Constitution talk
to me about what it is that you are part
of your practice as well talk to me
about what makes what sets you apart
well I definitely fall into the category
of the or the archetype of like growing
up in a difficult situation Brooklyn in
the 70s and 80s you know my dad losing
his bar when I was 18 years 17 years old
and just growing up in a bar and just
seeing casts all the time I think and
then practicing martial arts for many
years and running marathons I think I
just got a level of discipline and
fortitude that you know I think some
people maybe they have a reaction the
other way they become you know they give
up or whatever I for whatever reason
just grew up a fighter and I still have
that fighter mentality you know they now
super aware that the analogy is I use
you know are these war and violent ones
or you know or non-violence in the case
of the Jedi and samurai just violence is
last resort so you know I I am
incredibly hard-working and dedicated
and loyal and maybe you know to a fault
at times just not letting things go
right so I have a hard time letting
things go company's failing you know
business is failing projects family I
just haven't never-say-die attitude
which is probably long-term not a great
idea for returns being able to cut your
losses and give up and move on and use
that space to do another project is
likely the better scenario as an
investor and as an individual but you
know I I just don't like giving up I
like to fight until the last you know
arrow the last bullet no I think I'm not
moving forward do you think you'll maybe
try and try and try and develop that a
little bit moving forward or is it
something that you're glad is a curse
that you have to suffer for the
strengths that it gives you yeah I kind
of like it I'll be honest I kind of like
it I like you know being against the
odds
you know I like the fear I sleep better
at night knowing I fought till the end
you know and those are like that's my
job
yeah I mean when I'm with the founder I
always tell the founder you know what do
you want to do you want to keep fighting
or do you want to you know close this
chapter of your life and move on to the
next one we will be here either way if
you want to keep fighting I'll fight
with you if you want to shut the company
down or sell it for parts
to Google or Facebook and spend two or
three years there licking your wounds
and resting investing and collecting a
giant salary on the roof of hooli while
drinking cocktails or whatever fine
let's do it
and then we'll come back in two or three
years and kick ass again and so I kind
of leave it up to the founder that's the
balance I found my natural inclination
is to fight fight fight and never give
up because I've seen so many times that
you know month 18 or month 30 founder
figure something out and the company
goes supernova and sometimes the idea is
just not a great idea and so you should
where the market conditions are just
horrible and you're and you're just
fighting against something that you
cannot beat you know like if you're
fighting against like you know a tsunami
like it's you can't swim your way out of
a tsunami
you know likelihood right and you
probably want to retreat so there's
there's a time for training it's just
not in my nature generally and that and
I think it I think it's actually a
limiting factor at times for me it
probably should cut my losses on a lot
of things and just say yeah you know it
doesn't look like this business is gonna
work out I wish you luck with it and we
have to focus on the winners I have a
very hard time doing that I know VCS
would do it really wow I'm just amazed
that they can just be like yeah that
didn't work we've committed as much
capital as we want we're gonna get off
the board and we wish you luck let us
know if there's any way we can help and
I'm like wow okay super rational
approach just it's a much more efficient
approach I think I said I see VC is
doing all the time they're just like
yeah it's not a fit for us you know
we're not gonna keep going but you know
we'll give up our board seat and yeah if
you want to buy us out for ten cents on
the dollar whatever you know what's your
company you do what you want but they
kind of walk away from it yeah it must
be challenging I would find it
challenging to not become emotionally
invested you know to not have that that
part of me that wants more than what the
figures say that has faith beyond what
the balance sheet shows me beyond what
the what the stats are I don't know I
don't know whether that's yeah
defying I don't know whether that's
trying to try to personify businesses
almost as beings you know with
personalities and stuff like that yeah I
mean in order for another door to open
sometimes you gotta close one and
sometimes you got to reinvent yourself
so it's you know I used to be a
journalist and you know I think I took
that as far as I wanted to take it I
still dabble by doing this podcast etc
but it's not exactly I don't do it for
journalistic reasons exactly and so
sometimes you got to close the door on
one chapter of her life in order to
focus your energy on another it's pretty
much that simple yeah yeah and for
founder's especially because you can't
do three or four companies at once or
two or three projects at once it never
really results in an outlier success
right people look at what I'm doing
they're like oh my god you're doing so
many things and it's like yeah just if
you actually looked at what we're doing
it's all very strategic it looks like
there's a lot of activity but it's
really just two types of activity one is
providing a bunch of information to
founders that help them and two is
investing in them that's really
everything we do falls into those two
buckets so it looks from the outsider
looking in like you're potentially
spinning an awful lot of different
plates
whereas sure he's making dream
streamlined into two very discrete areas
which allows you to then scale the
volume that you're doing that correct
yeah I mean we have one thing like
podcasts and events and books right so
like oh you wrote a book oh you doing a
podcast oh you're doing a lot of podcast
episodes oh you did a second podcast
angel oh and you're doing the launch
festival and scale and founder
University and Angel University and
angels ominously yeah those are all one
thing that's just a way to meet people
in the industry and let them you know
share knowledge with each other and we
as the hosts of the sharing of that
knowledge hopefully people remember our
names so we can do number two invest in
their companies that's it it's literally
two things but you know if you looked at
our asana project board or our notion or
you know our customer support line
whatever like you would see
a lot of different activity so it's sort
of like wow just need does a lot of
things it's like yeah they do Star Wars
native Marvel and Marvel does Avengers
plus Marvel does you know these other
brands or whatever they do you know
people outside the Avengers they're
doing spider-man and you know the x-men
as well right but then you look at all
of it it's like yeah they entertain
people
okay do they do anything else well they
do the parks but that's entertaining
people they do okay so they entertain
people what else they do they let you
buy stuff that they entertained you with
oh okay so I can buy like a Star Wars
figure yep you can buy us you can buy a
Star Wars lightsaber you can make one
yourself you can buy a Marvel t-shirt
you buy a Marvel lunchbox okay so their
business is entertaining you and then
selling you merchandise that was burned
into your brain because you watched you
were entertained by it got it there's
been so deeply do you forgot that they
were doing it forgot that they were
doing something different I mean what
what other business do they have you
know you look at and say the theme parks
are different or there's all these
different themes in the theme park right
they did Star Wars land they do whatever
land this land that land Pixar Cars Land
whatever they have Epcot Center at
Disney World Disneyland whatever it's
called the same thing they're
entertaining you you pay the money they
entertain you and you maybe you buy
something on the way out that's it any
other is there something so symbolic or
structural that people should be looking
to to apply for that which is where you
have a particular skill set within your
life how can I then scale that skill set
so that it then dips into other areas
I'm allowed to then iterate on that on
that particular ability it's good to
understand what you're good at that's
for sure
I like to tell people what their
superpower is as I perceive it and I or
I ask them like do you think your
superpower is this and you know
different superpowers could work for
different things some people are
engineers like Elon is an engineer at
his heart like he's really a physicist
and engineer who knows how to build
stuff
and if you look at what he's building
like he's really good at metal like a
lot of what he does is like building
parts and metal and shaping it so that
it can go to space or that electric car
can be lighter and go further range and
a lot of the [ __ ] he learned that SpaceX
went to Tesla and Tesla to SpaceX like
material science and engineering is what
he does and people will think like oh
there's a lot more going on here it's
like is there right like he's and he's a
he's an engineer and he's a great
engineer and people you know look at him
more like Steve Jobs or whatever Steve
Jobs wasn't an engineer right and iving
Steve Jobs was a marketer
all right he knew a packager like he
really understood how to package and
market something to people simplify it
maybe like maybe he's at his core Steve
Jobs was like just a great designer of
products right and you know a brand
builder he built a brand and packaged
stuff he's really a packager and then
think about it like he made this package
Apple it meant something evokes
something simple clean opening the box
beyond the toy engine store using it all
that yet all the experiences so it's
kind of like an experienced designer
yeah I just Corey's an experienced
designer actually they're probably the
best way to say it he's an experienced
designer but agree cuz the stores and
experiencing using your phone using your
laptop opening up your phone taking it
out of the box it's all that experience
and so yeah you need to know what you're
good at where I'm a talker but my skill
set is talking that's my superpowers
talking and so I do a podcast and then I
talk to founders and I run an
accelerator where you talk a lot about
people's hopes and dreams and track in
strategies to succeed so talking is a
good one precision with your speech is
something that I think is a very very
under regarded superpower something that
I encourage a lot of the people that are
listening to do if they're not having a
conversation with a friend for 30
minutes every week why are they
undistracted and they're talking about
something that they care about and that
they're genuinely engaged in I find the
process of doing a podcast and recording
I find it therapeutic and sharpening and
honing in terms of the skill and what it
then enables me to do outside of that in
a way that
never had before I did this and I would
you feel more energy when you finish the
podcast than when you started
yes right so you're an extrovert not an
introvert you come out of a discussion
like this with more energy more inspired
than you do going into it and people who
are introverted would come out of this
and feel exhausted and they would need
to take a break and read a book or take
a nap or be alone and so that is really
the enter the energy of those two
different archetypes of humans
introverts or extroverts and knowing
that like some people you interview them
and they're just like I this was like
exhausting for me right other people
they are like great let's do our - let's
do our three you know they just want to
keep talking and so you know it's very
important for you to understand what
your skillset is what your personality
is what you enjoy and then lean into
that because the truth is when you're
starting a company you can always get
other people to fill in so if you're
Elon and you're a great engineer or
you're Steve Jobs and you're great you
know experienced designer or you're a
great talker and you know or you're
great sales executive you can you can
acquire those other skills from other
team members you don't need to have them
so this idea that there's one type of
founder I get asked that all the time
how do you pick the founders what
founders succeed most often and the
founders that succeed most often are the
ones who are self possessed and don't
give up and it doesn't matter if they're
introvert extra it doesn't matter if
they're sales marketing product
developer engineer visionary talker
you know leader manager all those
different archetypes succeed all the
time there is no commonality I don't
think other than people who are super
self possessed and they're very focused
and they don't give up so if you're
gonna look for traits introvert
extrovert you know what job they did
previously and how well they did that
job it's probably not as important as
those other software skills which are
actually the harder ones which is does
this person really care about this idea
are they going to quit will they give up
where are they going to you know build a
plan get a team and pursue the goal and
it really is that simple what's the goal
here what's the plan
and who's going to execute the plan and
man I can't tell you the number of times
you know you'll ask that to a founder
and they don't have a plan and they
don't have a goal and I tell everybody
our goal here when they come work at
launch our investment company watch dot
co you can see our website is just
simple website anyway what we do here at
launch is we invest in companies and our
goal is to be the best investors in
Silicon Valley though the best investors
in the world period we want to be the
best investors in the world so we just
work backwards - what does that mean
well we think it means supporting
founders early that's the tactic we're
using you know that's the plan and the
plan is to invest in 80 90 100 companies
a year and in ten years have a thousand
investments and invest ten times as much
in the winners as we do in the ones that
fail and go out of business that's it
that's the plan let's execute on
podcasts big part of it podcast we get
to put our founders on the podcast this
week in startups we get to put investors
on the podcast angel podcast com we get
to meet new founders on the podcast I
met the founder of kaam kaam and
invested in the company because he was
on the podcast and it's a tool you know
it's a tactic it happens to be a tool
and tactic that is in my wheelhouse as
the leader of the company right but I
make it very clear for people this is
why we're here and you know what it's a
lot of work to work with a hundred
companies a year because that means we
got to meet thousands and we have to
sort through ten over ten thousand to
meet with a couple thousand you know
we're gonna meet with two or three
thousand companies this year after
having gotten pitched by over 10,000
right so just start thinking about those
numbers so if we meet two or three four
thousand companies in order to get down
to a hundred investments it's a lot of
work it's a lot of work and you said
when in 50 people tential pay off for
the Android which is the asymmetry
exactly why it's there and nobody knows
and nobody there's the punchline nobody
knows what's gonna work so by the way
we're going to place a large number of
bets meet that we're gonna place a
hundred bats
after meeting thousands of people after
sorting through tens of thousands and we
don't actually know that it might not
work which one of the hundred every year
is going to be the breakout and in fact
if we all bet if the twelve members of
the team each picked two companies each
I doubt that we would even picking 25 of
them I don't think the majority of
people would pick the winner I don't
think I thought Kham Kham would be the
second best company in my portfolio I
did think Boober wasn't gonna be you
know a very successful company but I
thought a billion or two billion dollar
company not a sixty billion dollar
company so I was off by sixty thirty to
sixty a quite a bit yes so even even
though I knew it was a winner I didn't
know the magnitude of it you know and
Robin hood-like stock trading after
Millennials like I invested in that
company and didn't think it was gonna
work
I thought the founders are incredible
I'm not sure their first ideas gonna
work I think I'm probably their second
or third and I was wrong and delighted
to be wrong is the best way of doing the
best way to be wrong in history yeah
it's to place a bet and win you know it
would be like walking up to the to the
betting window and be like yeah I'm
gonna place a bet on this team and you
you picked the wrong team and then you
intended they give you the slip your
team loses you go to rip up the slip and
you look that you oh I made a mistake oh
I bet on the other team oh I won on
[ __ ] test okay great like literally
that's the job of an investor you just
don't know which ones are gonna win so
you just basically treat everybody who's
in your portfolio amazing you try to
just be as supportive as possible which
is you know again as like life is pretty
simple just find the best people you can
invest in them support the heck out of
them if it doesn't work out and they did
a good job and pat on them again come
back they'll do it again because it I
got to question Utley do another company
again they may fail again but you know
like I said three out of four foul then
you only need to do four to get to a
winner and all likelihood I get it I got
two questions before we finish up Jason
first one yeah going back to podcasting
someone who's been in the space for
quite some time sixty million plus play
is that even more now 160 million
probably more but whatever I mean we did
10 we've been doing it for 10 years and
over a thousand episodes so it's still a
booty pockets I mean we're only talking
about 200,000 people listening to every
episode it's no Joe Rogan it's not
millions were of people listening to
everyone it's you know it's a booty
pockets about a very specific niche
thing but it that niche thing we're
better than anybody are doing mm-hmm
so I think that's what's important been
in space for a long time where do you
see the podcasting space evolving over
the coming years what's next more of the
same well I think that I think the
listening the listener ships gonna you
know double in the next year or so
because I think we're like right at this
tipping point where it's starting to hit
the public consciousness and like with
this election cycle the fact that Bernie
Sanders was on Joe Rogan or you know but
that you know even presidential
candidates are and not just Andrew yang
right like not just like the tenth
person in the race but you know the top
person in the race is are going on
podcast or people who are writing really
important books are now looking at the
podcast as the better way to sell their
book than going to the press and
consumers are realizing reading
journalists and publications is fine and
you know once in a while there's gonna
be like a really important story and
that's great but overall if you really
want to go deep into a subject there's a
podcast for it that's going to be better
and it be better to hear from the
subject for an hour or two than to read
the story where they were quoted once or
twice that that's why journalists the
savvy ones are getting so into
podcasting they're realizing they'll get
more out of the same subjects in the
same amount of time by recording it and
releasing it whole that's the big unlock
so when I had Dan Rose formerly a
Facebook and Amazon now a co 2 he's the
only person who's ever worked for Jeff
Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg and he did an
incredible podcast and you know it
probably would be very shy if the Wall
Street Journal New York Times Washington
Post TechCrunch recode or any other
person called him because their guard
would be up and like okay what's the
story oh you're doing an anti-facebook
story oh you're doing an anti Amazon
story oh you're doing an anti
book and Amazon sorry anti Oh Jeff besos
gave away ten billion dollars to fight
global warming and nobody has ever put
up a fraction of that oh but he didn't
give away all of his money so ever let's
criticize him because he only gave away
ten percent of I was like literally the
guy just gave away the largest gift in
the history of giving except for Bill
Gates and Warren Buffett but I think it
might still be the single largest gift
ever and put some number three in
philanthropy I think or four but it's
not it I think it's gates and literally
yesterday all the press was criticizing
him and and the press is wondering why
the top subjects don't trust him or
don't want to work with him or why
Trump's rhetoric on fake news is so
powerful the reason why Trump is able to
say fake news is not because the news is
fake it's because journalists haven't
been doing a great job balancing out and
be and and you know going straight down
the middle with objective journalism
because journalists have picked aside
they gave up objective journalism and
they went towards link baiting in order
to save their publications right because
fox showed if you pick a side you win so
the New York Times is like okay we'll
pick the left MSNBC on the Left Fox on
the right Wall Street Journal on the
right so everybody's just picking aside
and your subscriptions go up so if you
pick a side your subscriptions go up
anybody in the middle is toast if you're
gonna go straight down the middle people
are just like oh okay well this doesn't
make me emotionally vested in what
you're doing you want to take down Trump
great you want to keep in Trump in
office and you want to troll the libs
great I'll give you money for those two
things but I'm not gonna give you money
for objective journalism right down the
middle and you know journalists have
responded to that market condition and
you know it's a the proper decision in
terms of keeping the lights on it's the
wrong decision in terms of building
trust with subjects the subjects just
don't trust the press anymore that you
know I don't agree with Trump : the
press fake news I don't think the news
is fake I think they're just have an
agenda and they have a point of view in
a perspective now but they're still
presenting it as objective
even though it's no longer objective
like if all these press people are on
Twitter dunking on Jeff Bezos for giving
away ten billion dollars and then they
write about Bezos it doesn't feel
objective anymore it feels like they're
all anti-capitalist anti-u n-- oh that
there's a group of them that are just
super anti capital is super socialist
you know and it's just depressing like I
would rather see that I get contacted by
journalists literally nine out of ten
times it's some negative story and one
at ten times maybe they're on background
and I can't tell if it's negative or not
but it used to be when I got contacted
ten times a lot of journalists in the
tech business be like hey is it have you
seen anything interesting and I'd say
yeah you know I'm doing this company
blockable oh we got this company uber or
you should check out this company Robin
Hood they're really smart folks and they
write a profile on them and they would
talk about what they were doing and why
they were doing it it was super
interesting like that was really great
because you were presenting to the
audience new stuff coming the only
criticism was maybe the tech press is a
little too cheerleader II but yeah other
things yeah I have an advertorial that I
mean I think the tech industry press
were fans of technology that's how it
started yeah like if you were writing
about tech you probably loved pcs in the
80s and software in the 90s and the
internet and the late 90s into 2000 you
loved gadgets if you're doing it yet you
just were a fan of the technology and
what it could do and you love the people
in the industry and then the industry
got so big that you know it needs to be
criticized because there are bad things
that have occurred but we've lost that
magic of like hey let's discover
something new and write about it they
just don't journalists don't do it
anymore cuz it doesn't nobody clicks on
it like you don't get clicks on Twitter
for saying Jason invested a hundred
thousand in this new company that's
gonna try to change housing let me tell
you about it like that's not gonna get
as much as you know Bezos gave away only
ten percent of his money and he didn't
guarantee how he's gonna give it away or
over what time period or who he's giving
it to and like they'll find every reason
to criticize him and how he gives away
ten billion dollars to stead of saying
Wow amazing who would like to give ten
billion dollars next what an amazing
gift because America is not spending on
you know what countries are spending ten
billion
fighting global warming I don't know
yeah this is a great example you know we
should be having a month we should be
having Bezos on TV high-fiving him and
instead they're gonna be like oh you
have too many drivers driving around
causing pollution driving you know
Sprinter vans around or you're killing
the environment with cardboard it's like
okay yeah that there's a story about
cardboard and sure we could write that
story but what you take a moment to let
that sink in that he's decided to put
ten billion dollars of his own money
it's a big number
towards you know raising awareness for
global warming insomnia and the crazy
thing between those two situations the
first one being you've done a thing or
this is something which is happening and
Bezos putting up ten billion is both of
those things are news like that is news
it's a definition of news a thing has
happened which is potentially Meuse
worthy just that one of them has been
spun a lot harder and been used as this
crutch to push what some people would
call an agenda and I think what you've
mentioned there about Trump it's the
fact that the they said the best lies
contain elements of truth right and
that's why that lies with truth the
devil mixes lies with truth there it is
the Exorcist William Peter Blatty
really great book if you want to read it
yeah and lead you in the follow-up
really good books i watch i watch the
legion is that the one whether or not
they're in a like motel type cafe thing
in nursing home all hell breaks loose
lots of bad things happen anyway the
books are better because the books are
really about Catholicism and God and
pain and suffering and why would adjust
God allow suffering and the devil and
evil so it's really through the lens of
Catholicism you know a priest trying to
come to terms with his own faith and it
just has a little bit of like this
horrific edge to it with murder and why
does murder and pain and suffering exist
in the world like there's a scene in it
where there's a a group of people who
have no it's a little graphic but there
were people who don't have the ability
to feel pain like something wrong with
their nervous system so they don't feel
pain so if you
to put a cigarette out on their leg or
if a cigarette fell on their leg and
burned them they wouldn't feel it and
there's just a senior's remember is very
evocative of a little girl who's
suffering that disease who wanted to
look out the window she climbed on to a
radiator in the ratty or turned on when
she was looking out the window and she
got burned on her legs and didn't feel
it why would God allow that to happen
right and that's actually you know why
that movie is so powerful is because
even though you don't get that from the
movie explicitly it's kind of this
undertone where are you trying to figure
out like the nature of evil why does
evil exist in the world right it's like
one of those core you know mysteries of
life like what why why do people do evil
things what is the point of it all why
do people blow things up why is there
terrorism why they're murderers like
serial killers whatever in a world
that's gone it's a difficult question to
answer very difficult we got to God it
only took us an hour final questioner
final final question Jason do you have
any cool tech on your radar at the
moment cool tech on my radar I am
particularly interested in robotics
outside of factories I think it's a very
you know interesting space that is going
to get very big I'm also very interested
in education that is self-paced and
occurs you know online or in small
groups
but that is a student-led kind of you
know selfish try what do they call it
there's a term for when it's student-led
but I you know I I like to look at the
areas I look at markets where technology
hasn't had a huge impact and for me you
know robotics people doing like manual
labor that sucks is one and that could
be very interesting for Humanity and
then another one is housing and even
housing plus robotics is kind of
interesting to me like robots building
houses
education where the education system is
super screwed up in the United States
I'd love to see more and more solutions
for you know we're seeing these ISAs
income sharing agreements where people
agree to share $30,000 whether their
salary over the next five years in
exchange for you teaching them how to be
a programmer or something like that or
there are websites that'll teach you you
know very niche websites one to become a
dancer like Steve's eco we invested in
ste zy o CO and you know or brilliant
org which teaches people math this idea
that there gonna be a vertical site
that's just really good at teaching you
one thing it's fascinating to me because
people go for these giant education that
cost fifty thousand a year and they put
themselves into a quarter million
dollars in debt and then their first job
out of school is 40 or 50 K so you know
after taxes if they're making $40,000
and they're 200 debt they've got a five
to one ratio of you know after-tax
income to their debt load it's just
never gonna be paid off right even if
they lived with their parents and paid
off twenty thousand dollars a year I
lived off the other twenty thousand it
would take them ten years to just get to
zero they'd be 31 years old before they
were able to even consider having any
kind of a life it's bizarre
so yeah just look at those big broken
markets things that are hard and just
try to think as an investor god I can't
wait for a founder to take on this one
block ables block BL okay ble blockable
comm is doing modular housing and I'm
super excited about that Cafe X is doing
we're about a coffee machines that will
make coffee 24 hours a day in places
where you can't get a good cup of coffee
give you food all with like a robotic
arm and you know people like oh that
seems like overkill it's like yeah it's
overkill until you start making like a
cold foam you know dirty chai and you're
getting espresso from here and you're
getting the chai from the tap and then
you're putting some cold foam on it
right and then you put a donut on the
side or a scone okay so now the robotic
arms done four or five things right
you start thinking every year the
robotic arm doesn't one or two more
steps right eventually the robotic arm
could be making a hamburger or a pizza
or whatever it is right
so there's coffees just I think the
first area where you'll start to see
robots be able to prepare a cup of tea
or coffee and do it perfectly when you
know when a human doesn't I love the
fact that coffees the first frontier for
robotics to get into that we all require
it it's a human right to have coffee
you know just robots outside of the
factory in a factory it makes total
sense like move this over here
stamp it move it down the line it's a
little more complicated when zoom is
trying to make pizza right like pizza is
probably the 50th thing on the list you
should do coffees like the first you
know or the first might be just yeah I
mean I think coffees are pretty good
first trophy is definitely the first we
can agree on that Jason well it's the
first time I you know I looked at every
single robotics company and only one of
them Cafe acts had done everything soup
to nuts like they there was no human
intervention and then when you look at
the pizza
you looked at the burger there was still
the human who had to kind of keep an eye
at the robotic arm and you had to have
humans in the store once you I mean once
you start putting humans in the store
it's like wow okay what's the point
even could've done the thing yeah yeah I
mean then that doesn't mean there won't
still be people you know just like cars
may have replaced horses like still not
horses still get to exist right and we
just may not have you know thousands of
horses suffering in the middle of London
or New Castle does that mate wait you're
in Newcastle correct Geoff know if I the
spent if you buy the Spanish city little
Spanish Spanish city is that the Spanish
cities not like a outside of Newcastle
is the thing called Spanish city which
is a Spanish city is like an amusement
park are you thinking of thinking
Newcastle Australia no hold on a second
Spanish city one Spanish cities if I've
lived in the northeast of England for 31
years and there's a Spanish city near me
and I've never heard of it I'm gonna be
really embarrassed
Spanish city is a dining yeah
dining and leisure center in Whitley Bay
a town in North 10 aside is that near
you or no Whitley Bay is about 10 miles
from where I am but you've just picked
like what is this Way's spawn is it just
a place like a restaurant or something
why do you know about this
well because it's in a famous song
called Tunnel of Love by a band called
dire straits okay
where Mark Knopfler spent a lot of time
at the Spanish city and he wrote a
famous line like the Spanish city to me
when we were kids you can look it up but
it's just some gaff in Whitley Bay is
someplace I've got next time I go for
fish and chips on the seaside Oh puffs
inches and they actually by the Spanish
city put the lyrics to that song tunnel
of love you know who Mark Knopfler and
dire straits are of course
wait now when they say Geordie boy where
does the Geordie boy come from okay so a
Geordie is the colloquial term for
people from Newcastle so you have
Jordi's from Newcastle that would be
Brian Brian Johnson from ac/dc Geordie
yeah yeah martini you're a Geordie boy
technically technically I'm a smoggy
because I'm from Middlesbrough which is
about 40 miles south of here and my dad
would be a maqam because he's from
Sunderland which is so you got the three
big cities Newcastle Middlesbrough in
Sunderland it's all very very tight-knit
yeah what do they kill people from
Brooklyn Bridge and Tunnel is a
derogatory term from anybody who had to
take the bridge or tunnel into Manhattan
so that could be Queens or Bronx or New
Jersey even okay yeah um now if you're
just from Brooklyn you from Brooklyn I'm
from Middlesbrough but you let's get
let's come up with something we need to
do rebrand let's get a new Brendan well
know there was a and there's a famous
song called sailing to Philadelphia that
marking off a road and it's about
it's actually one of the most beautiful
songs ever written and he did the vocals
with James Taylor but it's about the
people who bill drew the mason-dixon
line which was Charlie Mason and
Jeremiah Dixon and those were chewing
the surveyors and I believe Jeremiah
Dixon
it was the Jordy boy so he was a Geordie
boy who did the mason-dixon line in
America good heritage is a very great
heritage that yeah um
Jason we made it man we made it thank
you very much we did it made it to the
end bit up so bright I let me know when
the pod comes out I'm glad to be episode
150 and let me know when you plan on
leaving the lighthouse you know I used
to have I used to have and I promise you
and I will I can send you a photo to
prove it I used to have right there that
same size Brooklyn Bridge really promise
you intact why is that why did I change
you had an affinity well that's a good
question well why the Brooklyn Bridge
didn't start with that I liked it the
geometric pattern so it's taken from the
second from the bridge and you can see
the slice running away from me and you
can see all of the wires running up and
across and I just found that I found it
very mesmerizing I found it very
beautiful and then I have you walked
across it yet
what was that have you walked across the
Brooklyn Bridge I haven't no I went to a
stag do we would call it bachelor party
we call it stag do into a stag do in New
York last year and I didn't get to spend
any time outside of outside go ahead go
ahead and walk over the Brooklyn Bridge
a lot of people do it every day and
you'll be part of history if you go do
it it's pretty - pretty amazing
experience to walk across the bridge to
ride my bike across the Brooklyn Bridge
roll time I want to stand in the spot
where my photo was my photo the photo
that was there I also want to find out I
can't find out where that lighthouse is
so one day listener a listener sounds
very simple you take a picture of that
lighthouse and you just put it into
google reverse image search you'll find
it there we go that's why you get paid
the big books that's all right man thank
you beyond the pot pleasure thank you
cheers now back
[Music]
you